tiens et mme scott doublé de choc
morgana brochette teva le score des
turcs est ma mémoire celle pour je paie
ma grand mère ouais aller le x 4 faut la
peau on balaye un téléphone les brus
longue
saura toucher à tout
ça arrête tes conneries emploi tu me
lâcher et ça c'est des conneries
je trouve rien sur internet là c'est
bizarre qu'on truc non mais forcément
une explication
lotus est pas cherché en vain non mais
ça va ça c'est bon état à nos consoles
mais je mets mange mais oui mais avec
brûlures bas mais non alors c'est bon
c'est bon bah nan télécommande médicaux
alors
voici pour moi aussi alors cigarettes
aux clous
j'ai compris des allergiques à la
technologie
arthur c'est quoi ces histoires ah non
mais en fait je peux plus touchées
d'ordinateurs monsieur si vous voulez un
jour de congé suffit de le demander
gentiment pas la peine de faire le fou
ah non le seastar yeux en sueur ça
dérange pas de décrocher pour moi est
moi ça me voudrait transférer les appels
à facturation à la canton abbaoui
jusqu'à ce que je fais depuis deux
heures ça ça vous dérange pas de juste
cliquer et glisser dans le mail comme ça
juste passer aussi ci joint le dossier
le erp
je fais un petit café - et on va pas sur
facebook parce que sinon respire respire
et on relâche
non franchement tout va bien simplement
ce type d'allergie
franchement j'ai jamais vu jamais mais
du coup du coup je vais dire non je vais
en parler des collègues mais je sais pas
ah bah oui c'est vrai
en même temps c'est dommage parce que je
viens de l'acheter là j'étais hyper
content de pouvoir les sinon faites moi
plaisir ça brûle type pas sur moi ok de
nom
à
au 11e bout - ah non j'ai rien sinon je
viens demain à café indiqua t cheveux tu
as remarqué et arthur réflexe au but
dont le verdict à la technologie mais
attends comment tu fais pour et sur
facebook du coup m'a dit que je ne
vivais pas et comment tu fais pour 5,7
alors confié j'ai pu filer le pad et et
pour les sites porno c'est contagieux ou
pas pensé à ça
seulement quelques mètres d'arthur
alors pure ça va partir je t'appelais
arthur premier cas de technophobie au
monde
allergie à la technologie alors est ce
que tu peux nous expliquer comment sa
semaine romaine
je vous prends pas les emails et pour
les sites de tu commences à la pompe aux
sites de cul non
monica c'est exactement ce qu'il fallait
et à comprendre mais juste un livre la
balustrade
arthur on ne voulait pas travailler pour
des raisons qui vous regarde
ok mais vous pourriez au moins faire
l'effort de venir en réunion à y avait
une réunion c'est ça on vous a prévenu
par mail la semaine dernière à moi je
peux plus voir mes mails bientôt
boulevard est où votre salaire alors
assez dense a sincèrement c'est pas
mieux at a toujours quand même mon
allergie way
[ __ ] ça fait tellement plaisir tous
vos appareils je veux plus personne
c'est un truc de fou
je me fais chier chez moi je suis réduit
à asnières les résumés des films ou de
dvd sont mariés mais des débats
anniversaire de charlotte hier soir
c'était marrant pour des bonnets j'étais
beaucoup avaient fait un truc mais quoi
maintenant on était bien dans
l'événement facebook pourtant je peux
plus surfer en temps réel et texto je
peux plus les son téléphone ya le dire
et tu m'appelles 1 qui m'appelle ok
google ou est-ce que j'habite
au bout de joie
arthur quelles surprises nous devons
mettre fin au non t'inquiète bottes
étaient occupées c'est normal entre ça
fait plaisir de tous bords arthur c'est
gentil d'être passé mais j'ai q2 conseil
a demandé comment tu fais pour vivre
sans technologie dans sa santé théologie
sans ordinateur sans son gps gps et les
cartes électroniques pour se repérer
tapas à ma vie je suis tu lises des cats
par électronique
je suis quoi oui j'ai pas de conseil à
te donnait pourtant ta maladie là mais
j'ai peut-être quelques trucs pour toi
tout seul je m'en sers plus s'attira
peut-être
oh [ __ ]
oui
ça marche ça marche i had j'entends sa
voix
vas-y dit un truc oh [ __ ] j'entends ta
voix tu es pas dans la même pièce 1 to
do the neck frappe c'est mon conjoint ce
soir j'organise une teuf et franchement
ce soir
c'est mon style et les vinyles ça semble
une tâche qui ça fait plutôt mal
j'ai pas et elle coule ne pas prendre un
truc pas mal dans ta maladie au sérieux
du coup voilà je le ferai un petit
cadeau pour
voilà a priori tu n'as pas besoin de
leurs charges et souvent et tu peux le
démarré comme ça
et après tout ce joue comme ça
oui c'est super mais ouais cet actif du
coup mais voilà tout est tactile du sens
de page
c'est super bien fait
citrix appsteur mais ces estimations et
ce trailer
ça fait longtemps maintenant
oh
nous
bordel là dedans ça a bien besoin de
rangement franchement arthur ah oui donc
c'est vrai que tu ranges tout t'aurais
pas trouvé le contrat de fournisseur
chinois par hasard la vie mais ce
dernier
oui blue cherche un truc arthur nous
avons beaucoup entendu parler de ces
dernières semaines vous êtes
officiellement le premier cas de
technophobie oui oui c'est bien ça vous
pouvez nous expliquer ce que c'est je
suis allergique et la technologie
donc je ne peux plus touchées
d'ordinateurs de tablettes et
smartphones plus rien non non non tous
les jeunes qui nous regardent doivent
penser c'est un véritable cauchemar
ils ont bien raison
dire ça
filles
ouais
m
mais du coup vous n'allez pas craqué
pour conjurer phone non non non de ce
côté là au moins je fais des économies
nous allons nous battre
on a tous envie de savoir comment vit-on
avec la technophobie comment on vit avec
la technophobie
on s'y fait